à Nicolas dans le sud de l'Ukraine à
quelques kilomètres seulement au nord de
Herson bonsoir à vous et Karim vous êtes
sur le terrain depuis deux semaines
maintenant avec Catherine nourrice 30
Mohamed Farhat et demi-tour de citer
toute l'équipe vous avez tourné arrête
sonne et en périphérie de la ville et
c'est surtout dans les villages voisins
désormais libéré des occupés pour nos
intimides retour à la maison
c'est vrai on est allé on a sillonné un
certain nombre de villages dans le blast
Delson et dans l'eau blast de nicolaïf
des villages qui ont vécu pendant de
longs mois sous le jour russe souffrant
de la violence de l'occupant alors
l'occupant c'est retiré mais derrière
lui il a laissé le chaos la destruction
des infrastructures notamment des
hôpitaux des écoles qui ont été
totalement ravagés des populations qui
n'ont pas eu parfois accès à
l'électricité pendant un an difficile de
se faire soigner également dans ces dans
ces villages où il y a essentiellement
il faut le souligner des personnes âgées
puisque beaucoup des hommes sont partis
au front des hommes de cette région
agricole alors c'est vrai que ça revient
timidement il y a un mouvement de retour
dans ces dans ces villages on se
réinstalle petit à petit prudemment
parce que le traumatisme de l'occupation
russe était encore extrêmement vif
certains nous ont confié vous avez peur
de voir les Russes revenir un jour mais
doucement la vie reprend peu à peu ses
droits dans ces dans ces villages des
villages qui parfois ont été rejoints
aussi par des habitants de Kerson
puisque à Carson la vie reste
extrêmement compliquée la ville de
cresson n'est plus sous occupations
russes Karim et ce depuis l'automne
dernier c'est une ville libre mais
surtout une ville meurtrie
c'est vrai c'est une ville meurtrie on y
est encore passé la journée
d'aujourd'hui des bombardements
incessants qui frappent cette ville qui
se trouve sur la ligne de front des deux
côtés il y a de l'artillerie
l'artillerie russe frappe à l'aveugle et
fait régulièrement des dégâts et des
victimes alors qu'il resonne il faut le
rappeler c'était une ville stratégique
qui avait été prise par les Russes assez
rapidement après le 24 février 2022 mais
qui a été reprise bien plus tard par les
par les Ukrainiens les Russes sont
encore là pas loin de l'autre côté du
Nieppe et c'est vrai que les conditions
de vie sont extrêmement difficiles et
pour vous